he's one of our favorites and he's Ryan
Leaf pac-12 network analyst former NFL
quarterback of course gave us one of the
great pieces of memorabilia in this
mancave the Ryan Leaf Colts Jersey now
for those who don't know the background
on this Ryan if he was gonna be drafted
number one overall by the Colts that was
the Jersey they were giving him a shot
promos I guess they game the Jersey he
had the jersey and then he of course was
drafted number two by the Chargers and
then Peyton Manning was drafted number
one overall so that's the Jersey he
would have been given on draft day had
he been selected by the Colts yeah and I
don't remember exactly how I got it back
but when I did and I was talking to
Paulie about it I he's like dude that
would look great in our man and I was
like I'm not I'm not doing anything with
it so yeah why not and it's it's always
been fun no matter what the ups and
downs I always can go to the the
mainstay of the Dan Patrick show and the
Leaf Colts Jersey hanging there are so
many looks second you know like a double
take when people come in and go wait
Ryan Leaf Colts Jersey and then you
explain it to them and they're like oh
that's cool I don't know if anybody else
would want it in their man cave but we
love it and it'll be prominently
displayed when we well that was my
question
oh yeah yeah the the leaf Colts Jersey
prominently displayed that's a one seat
of memorabilia in here I appreciate
that's that's up there on the list
alright
by the way Ryan works as a program
ambassador for transcend recovery in Los
Angeles chairs the focused intensity
foundation dedicated to removing the
financial barrier to treatment
he's also hosting a new docu-series
called bust which looks at the
emotionally damaging power of
expectations and the trials faced by
athletes as they attempt to recover from
their sporting disappointments and you
know this as well as anybody and we've
documented this throughout the years
down through the years of addiction to
pain pills being in jail the expectation
of being a you know second quarterback
taken overall and look at you now you
got a child MacGyver you got a wonderful
woman in your life
and everything's good yeah I mean it's
it's life though right there's still
things that happen and there's adversity
I think that's the bit always
the biggest problem is that I saw it as
failure success there wasn't that even
ground of like hey you know I had a
tough day but I'm doing the right things
moving forward it's interesting being in
the broadcasting world now that has been
an interesting concept working with
Sirius XM and and the other networks and
things like that because what
essentially I'm doing now is I'm telling
a story rather than being the story and
I really enjoy that part of it well what
would you say at the NFL rookie
symposium well I usually walk in and I
tend to say to the young man that are
playing football that just because
you're a great athlete doesn't make you
a good person and I think that's lost a
lot of times where you just assume that
you're on TV all the time and people
admire you and you're on a pedestal hey
I can do no wrong but usually elite
athletes have one of the most fragile
psyches there are and when it goes bad
it goes bad in a hurry
it's it's this this ability to overcome
those things and that's those that do
that are super successful and we watch
it happen every sin Tom Brady is the
perfect example of that I mean he's
easily an example of that but he's had
to overcome so much adversity and then
put himself in a position to be better
you're in you're out
and but at some point you know people if
they saw you they would be laughing at
you
not with you and and then to get over
that hurdle to say you know I want to be
laughing with you about this how long
does that take it took forever right I
mean it took me to the bottom right I
didn't even figure that out until I was
in prison right and I was helping other
people and it was it had nothing to do
with me right and I knew that when I got
out that that was gonna have to be the
foundation of who I was otherwise I was
gonna be resentful of everybody I was
gonna be so worried about what other
people think and that was a big part of
it I used that affirmation every morning
in the mirror I've been doing it for
about four years now what other people
think of me is none of my business and
it it took a long time for that to
burrow its burrow itself into my brain
and I understand it I completely
understand it now hey it's what I did
it's not who I am I got this other life
and I want to help others who have gone
through similar things like I have and
that's what we're doing with the
docu-series bus it's simply I all want
examples
guys who made it through the fire and I
want examples of guys who were still
struggling with that who are some of the
names that you're gonna feature I assume
that you you you venture into my story
just to help and make those individuals
relate now that's always worried someone
who you're gonna get to be a part of it
right is Johnny Manziel close to you see
a bust
well III I think that the word
associates with that some people have
brought to me the idea of Dale Earnhardt
jr. as a bust having never won a cup
title but was the most famous yeah you
know it's it's all different what people
interpret a bust is then the word gave
me such it was so it's such an angry
word and it's weird to think that way
because the Hall of Fame you have bus
yeah you know and then you go to the
opposite side of it and it's a failure
so I want to dive into that I want to
dive into the the individuals are that
may still be struggling with it but
those who did come through it well and I
want to understand why so maybe we can
teach somebody who deals with this I
mean a football career is very fleeting
right I mean mine lasted four years the
average is like two and a half it's over
in a hurry you may be 25 years old and
if you don't have another purpose if
your identity is tied into only that the
transition is terribly difficult we see
it all the time
also when you're drafted who was drafted
before you or after you also factors in
as well because anybody who was drafted
you know Sam Bowie was drafted ahead of
Michael Jordan right and you know we
just remember that Greg Oden was drafted
ahead of Kevin Durant if Peyton Manning
wasn't as successful as he was would you
be less of a bus
probably by I mean when you're drafted
alongside arguably the greatest to ever
play that does it the innovation of the
internet at the time I'm kind of dating
myself here it just had come out viral
videos things like that became this that
or the other so I do think they had
something to play into it the fact that
we were so closely compared to at the
time I think is a huge compliment
I do take that as a compliment yeah and
it was all on me
you can't blame you might have been
more talented coming out of college than
Peyton I've probably said that I mean
athletically talented but it's not
necessary buddy makes it to that level
is yeah I wanted but you know Payton's
edge was his mental agility to meet you
what you do from Sunday to Sunday that's
that's the key in the NFL I got away
with it in college being able to not
necessarily be Saturday to Saturday
because my talent was good enough at the
time but when you get to the NFL it's
the best players from every collegiate
team you're playing and it doesn't get
easier it gets harder
he's Ryan Lee for the pac-12 Network
analyst and of course the former NFL
quarterback all right if you're the
Arizona Cardinals what are you doing
well I think they already did it they've
took a big leap of faith by hiring Kliff
Kingsbury I mean that's huge a guy that
just got fired from a collegiate job is
now your new head coach so I think they
already did that and that means they
have to draft Kyler Murray and that
means they have to move Josh rose in
some way somehow their way now why do
you have to because they put so money
they put all their eggs in the basket of
Kliff Kingsbury and what offense he
brings to the table and Kyler Murray is
exactly that he's the hybrid of Lincoln
Riley and what Kliff Kingsbury does Josh
Rosen probably could find a way to fit
into it but it's it's different and why
if you had the opportunity if you're
jumping into this full-fledged as the
Arizona Cardinals simply are why don't
you go and get the guy that Kliff
Kingsbury knows he needs and wants I
mean you you it's a leap of faith go
all-in either go all-in or you know I
don't know what you're doing if you're
not doing that but it feels like the
Cardinals are saying to the rest of the
NFL hey we're not quite sure yet so we
really value Josh Rosen and if you value
him you got to give us a first-round
pick
I think they've it feels like they're
holding on to their leverage and there's
really no leverage there that is
somebody gonna pony up a first-round
pick for Josh I don't think anybody's
gonna pony up a first-round pick who
should go get him I think the Giants
should I think I it would be great if
the Giants went and got him and then
we're able to use that 6th and 17th pick
on a defensive lineman in an offensive
lineman I don't know if they can if that
could happen and they could have say
qualm barkley and the quarterback they
probably should have drafted a year ago
I think it would be a real win moving
forward for them and that in a place
right now where Gettleman is kind of
telling everybody
taking on that 21 million dollars in
dead money this year Hayward we're not
gonna be that we're not gonna be good
this year John Harbaugh the Ravens head
coach came out and said the Browns are
the most talented team in the division
which I thought was brilliant on his
part you know like hey you shine all
your lights over there and your
microphones focus on the Browns while we
just continue to do what we do and
Pittsburgh is gonna do what they do is
Cleveland the most talented team in the
AFC North there they're super talented
it's just you wonder although all those
egos together under a head coach that
has no experience is that going to
change or is it just gonna be like a
dumpster fire when things start to go
bad because it's still the Cleveland
Browns right I mean there's systematic
to this you know where there's always
been issues I would love to see it
happen I was thoroughly impressed with
Baker Mayfield a year ago and what he
was able to do and when you put those
kind of weapons around him but how do
you keep everybody happy that's that's
the key because I oh do Beckham wants to
show the world I'm still the baddest
dude in the NFL and and so he needs his
targets because he can't showcase his
talents and he can't rub it in to the
Giants unless you throw him the ball
well we just saw that go down in
Pittsburgh with Antonio Brown you know
just if you're not getting your touches
or you're not feeling you know you know
caress the right way while you're there
things become a problem we've seen Lee
in the NBA being able to kind of hang
together a bunch of stars we haven't
necessarily seen it in the NFL at least
successful NFL teams the New England
Patriots they get rid of people you know
they just Tom Brady's the key but
they've been able to move on from there
this seems like a dream team it really
does for all the Millennials out there
at everybody who watches through social
media and stuff these type of
individuals that are playing for the
Cleveland Browns are exactly what the
youngster is all watching and they're
thinking best team and the best team in
the NFL they should win they should be
on Monday Night Football every week
mentality but I'm gonna wait and see
like everybody else should they should
wait and see because I still think the
Pittsburgh Steelers are the still a
dominant force in that division
regardless of what did I do to I I think
that we sort of go why they lost in Tony
Brown and they lost Le'Veon Bell there
the Steelers yes I mean there's a reason
why they're always you know in the hunt
they're Ben Roethlisberger getting a lot
of criticism I know that we talk about
leaders and we kind of throw that out
there like he's a leader like I don't
know what a leader is in today's sports
world I know what it used to be but it
feels like you can lead by just example
or you can lead by words but then if you
don't play well but you're a leader with
your words then do they still respect
you like I'm trying to figure out where
Ben is and all of this how much does he
create and how much is he just a victim
here I think the second part of that
leading and not necessarily playing that
well right now could be contributed to
Eli Manning you know he's still this
amazing leader and they love him in the
clubhouse in the locker room with Ben
Roethlisberger they've always won the
Pittsburgh Steelers have been the
dominant force in the AFC North for the
most part battling with the the
Baltimore Ravens what they've been
winning and this was the first time
where you really saw cracks and when you
lose the magnifying glass just shows up
you can be you could be actually one of
the worst teammates but if you
contribute and you play well and you
show up and you're there I think the
biggest takeaway been about Ben
Roethlisberger's he's played injured and
in the NFL that is like a the Bronze
Star right you you play injured you show
up you're a leader that's how people
look at it he has he showed up and he's
played and he's played and he's played
he plays with that kind of style that
teammates really love well right now
they're losing and they had cracks in
the cement the locker room was discussed
a lot outside of the locker room which
has never been the case in Pittsburgh
the hole Antonio Brown drama that that
said a lot now that would be my only
worry unless by kind of pushing these
things away
they've reinstituted that focus and now
they're in a position to have Ben
Roethlisberger really lead that ballclub
other quarterbacks you like in this
draft definitely Dwayne Haskins I think
drew Locke has stepped up his workout
was was exceptional people are even
throwing him in the possibility being a
top ten pick and it's always that worry
from general managers that they have
that FOMO the the fear of missing out on
the franchise quarterback because that's
gonna be the answer what I found that
has happened recently is that you've
gone
and founded a durable and a competent
quarterback and there on that rookie
contract and you're able to go out and
build around you I'm interested to see
when Jared Goff's contract comes up I'm
pretty sure they're gonna pay Patrick
mahomes just because what he's done but
you watched some of these large
contracts that are weighing teams down
the inability to go out and surround
somebody like Aaron Rodgers with that
huge contract with the type of players
he needs because you just can't do it
himself that you're gonna see maybe that
fifth-year option coming up in teams
just going hey we had our channel we had
our run let's let's go back reload
find a quarterback in the draft and
build around it again and try to make
that run it will be interesting to see
how that moves along
I think Dwayne Haskins is one of those
guys you can pick up and he can be a dak
Prescott where he gets into a situation
does really well and then you have to
make a choice when those fight when that
fear comes are you is this our guy
which what does that mean nowadays when
you lose so much money because they're
being paid so much that you can't go out
and grab a key to leave or medomak ensue
and place that defense together and make
a Super Bowl run when the Raiders get to
Las Vegas is Derek Carr their
quarterback I I have a thought that he
may not be the quarterback this year
even I think if they could get Kyler
Murray they would they would get him
like that if you if you could say to
Gruden it's gonna cost you three ones
and you can get him that Gruden would go
all-in on him I'm still a little
hesitant about Kyler Mary and not
because of what a great talent he is I
just he's he's he's slight in size and
that's always gonna be the issue for him
but you make the comparison I was the
prototypical NFL quarterback at 6'5 230
pounds a night and I was a bust right so
I'm just a little hesitant if Jon Gruden
were to go do that that would be I don't
know if that would fill in with his plan
his blueprint his plan that he has in
place on what he's trying to do the clio
mac trade the mari cooper trade but he's
got a rookie quarterback contract there
you got a face going in to vegas with
him and antonio brown oh come on that's
what i mean Gruden's a horrible poker
player like he loves Cuyler murray i
think any any rookie quarterback i think
if he went out and got I mean I know
Cuyler Murray would be a big splash but
I think if you went out and was able to
find and get
rookie quarterback Dwayne Haskins drew
Locke one of those guys I feel like he
feels he could make that work I just
don't know if it's going to be Derek
Carr and in particular like you talked
about that contract is huge you got the
huge deal yeah I don't think that he's
their quarterback like but I think that
if they can get I think they're gonna
try to go up and or maybe they're gonna
use that top five pick and maybe they go
in on Haskins before the Giants do the
interesting idea about this draft and I
had somebody tell me recently that this
draft is so fully loaded defensively you
know that that if only defensive players
were drafted from 1 till 32 we're in New
England's picking they would still get a
unbelievable defensive player in pick
number 32 that's how deep it is I don't
want to take a quarterback because I
need a quarterback I have to take the
quarterback who's the right but the
drafts are littered with GM's who go oh
my god we got to go we got to get our
quarterback I will take Christian Ponder
will take Blaine Gabbert and you're
gonna know that's not that shouldn't be
the way it works it is because you
believe in in the fact that we pay our
franchise quarterback so much money in
our the face of the franchise that you
have to go and get it you we've seen in
the playoffs and we've seen I mean Tom
Brady of course is the the utter example
of but he also doesn't he finds ways to
make his contract difference that can
pay differently right he's not the
highest-paid player in the NFL he's
still a very highly paid quarterback but
when they pay all that money the
opportunity to go find those other
players is limited and I don't know if
Aaron Rodgers I think arguably one of
the greatest quarterbacks in the league
right now and I don't think anybody
argue with that I just don't know if
they'll ever win again I don't know if
they're gonna be able to put players
around him good enough to to show that
they lost Randall Cobb I thought they
were gonna maybe go after Antonio Brown
you know it's just you sort of look at
the Packers as half-full half-empty
we'll see what they do with the draft I
think there's a couple receivers that
are probably tangible opportunities for
them but you know the draft is always a
crapshoot this year it's really
defensive Laden I think it's gonna be
very big on that early on he's Ryan Leaf
it's always great to see a
congratulations on all your success and
where are you off to next we got gotta
get back to the city tonight
and
and do some work and then I'm headed
down to Florida the NFL you told me this
four years ago that the NFL would come
to me and say Ryan will you be a
representative of our NFL Legends
community where we help retirees and and
players trance
you know transition out I would have
told you were crazy and what an honor I
found that out this last week so I'm
heading down there for a summit this
week with Tracy Perlman and Chad
Pennington Mark Brunell those types of
guys that have helped players transit
they helped me transition when I didn't
feel like and this happened when we were
in San Francisco when I got was out of
prison for a year and I didn't want to
be in the public eye and you had me on
the show and things changed I went into
this lounge called the NFL legends
lounge and I walked in and I saw like
immediately four former teammates of
mine and they all came up to me and just
wrapped their arms around because I felt
like I didn't belong with any of them
right because I felt like I was a
failure and I walked into that room and
they told me we're all legends we made
it to the NFL you know hard that is and
I took Chad and hit Penningtons Han he
walked me around introduced me to
everybody they put their arm around me
and this has kind of been the journey
and what I've been doing for the last
four years what it's come to the
recovery community yeah I'm now gonna
get to do really in my peer group
because I don't want anybody else who
played in this league to ever feel like
they're less than or be as miserable as
I as I was at that time so that's a
great honor and the reaction that you
always get in those first couple of
appearances and and hopefully that opens
some people's eyes to who you are and
you know what what you are as a person
because I think everybody had that
impression that image of you and they
weren't quite sure if it was real or not
and hopefully you're getting these
opportunities because you came clean in
a variety of ways when you're when
you're transparent and vulnerable and I
never thought that was a strength I
always thought that was like I needed to
be guarded I can't let anybody see what
I consider weakness right and I had I
changed because of I have loss forced to
change and I had been of service to
others and when I came on your show that
day it was just I kind of just repealed
down those those bricks from that wall
and we had a conversation we were like
no I didn't know anybody else was
listening I was just talking to you yeah
and it changed my life
because
people got to see that but I also had to
back it up right there couldn't ever be
I was skeptical everybody should have my
I heard it and I went i've been around
before for and you have you've lived up
to it and and hopefully there's great
things down the road for you it's always
great to see some to see you guys he's
Ryan Leaf for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]